hey everyone
thanks for tuning in
hey everyone thanks for the
i think we have over 200 people here in
the house we're gonna leave a couple
more minutes for for people to show up
and join us
um
so thank you very much for being early
birds
here
uh well while people people join us
we can
do a little round of
presenting ourselves so i'll start i'm
jeff budiem the product team here at
hiking face
i'm happy to work with companies to
accelerate their machine learning and uh
super excited to show infinity to you
today
federico
well i'm federico pascual
i'm from the marketing team and yeah i'm
pretty excited to tell you more about
our new inference product
morgan
hi everyone we're happy to be there i'm
machine learning engineer working on
optimization there so yeah
and philip hi everyone i'm phillip i'm
tech lead at hiking face and also tech
lead for infinity and like happy to
demonstrate you what we have created
today
awesome i see we have people joining
from all over the world don't hesitate
say hi in the chat say where you from
uh super excited to uh to see you all
joining
um
while people continue to join maybe uh
i'll give a few words of context about
hugging face i'm sure most of you are
familiar with us
but to give you the the big picture
our mission as a team is to democratize
state-of-the-art machine learning and we
do this through open science we do this
we do it through our open source
contributions and we do it also through
our products and services
and i'm super excited to
show infinity to you
today hey greg hey alexander hey peter
we got new york germany
bay area
bangalore spain germany again
uh boston berkeley
minneapolis
amsterdam
korea italy
boulder
munich
turkey awesome
thank you thank you so much all for
joining
um
all right let's see
maybe one more minute
so one more minute um so i'm sure you're
familiar with uh transformers today
there are over 16 000 state-of-the-art
transformer models available
on our website at huggingface.go or
hf.co for short
free and public data sets that you can
access through our open source and
through our machine learning platform
so feel free to check it all out
today i'm going to start sharing my
screen and then federico you give me the
the go ahead to start
inception
all right whenever you're ready you let
me know
yeah let's go let's start
sweet all right let's get this show on
the road so infinity before i get too
deep uh into it i just want to restate
uh what it is that we want to
show you today
so infinity is a containerized solution
that you can deploy in your own
infrastructure whatever cloud you're
using whatever production environment
you have
so you can deploy fully optimized and
accelerated inference pipelines for
transformer models
so
now you know what it is all about
and in this uh session what i'm gonna go
through is first uh show you
what infinity is why we built it and how
it works uh and then philip is going to
walk you through a live demo of the
service to show you how you can do uh
how you can deploy infinity in your own
environment then we'll have a little
time for q a all right let's get to it
before
let's start with a little bit of a
guessing game
so
here it is
what do tesla gmail facebook and bing
all have in common
there are a lot of answers possible but
the one i'm interested in today is
transformers it's through transformers
that tesla drives the car
it's through transformers that gmail
will complete your sentences
it's through transformers that facebook
automatically translates the post from
your friends
and it's through transformers that bing
answers your questions when you ask them
in natural language and then there is
another piece to this which is all of
those services
all of those services um run billions of
predictions on transformers models every
day and that's a huge technical and
engineering feat
that big tech has been able to achieve
what infiniti is all about
is to enable this for the rest of us we
want every single company in the world
to be able to take advantage of
transformers models
the accuracy of transformers models but
in
a way that they can deploy at scale if
as efficiently as possible to enable
real-time use cases um and high
performance as facebook as tesla as
google and microsoft have been able to
achieve and what we've seen discussing
with hundreds of companies that use our
open source every day is that
transformers today it's still at the
research and development stage for a lot
of companies out there evaluating the
models building new use cases based on
those models that are still
issues that prevent those models to be
deployed in production on customer data
for
everyday real-time use and those issues
are the efficiency the time it takes to
make predictions on those models and the
difficulty of building that into
infrastructure
that scales
so today if you want to do that
as a machine learning engineer
you can either
use
black box solutions where you cannot
bring your own model or fine-tune the
model or understand what's under the
hood
or you can start from scratch and rely
on uh great open source projects out
there great uh cloud machine learning
platforms out there so you have to
cobble a solution together and that's
really really hard
to get right and to get the latency down
to that sweet spot of 20 to 50
milliseconds per prediction that really
enables scale that really enables
real-time use cases and i see three
layers
of uh engineering challenge in doing so
so the first one is those models the
transformers models are large models uh
they're hard to deploy they require
special
memory requirements special
hardware requirements and so the
deployment of the model is the first
challenge to tackle but then if you want
to
get better performance you have to
actually edit your model you have to do
things like compressing the model you
have to do things um like pruning
quantizing and all the methods uh
through which you can accelerate the
performance the efficiency of your model
um um directly but then to squeeze uh
the best possible performance and get
the accuracy benefits of transformers
while having the speed that is
compatible for large-scale uh workloads
then you have to go all the way down to
the hardware understand for the actual
cpu or gpu that you're going to be
running the model on what operators are
available and that low level
optimization is what enables
the performance that we're delivering
when talking to companies we observe
that typically it takes
two months
for teams of very highly skilled
engineers
to deploy transformer models and
accelerate them to get that level of
speed and these uh type of experience
and skills are very rare within
companies so it's a big challenge for
organizations and because we at hugging
face
are at the center of the ecosystem for
transformers transformer models
then
our users are looking for us to
solutions
whether it's the financial services
industry or the healthcare industry or
the consumer tech industry they're all
coming to us uh with requests to
accelerate uh their models
and because we are the center of the
ecosystem of transformers we also
benefit uh from deep collaboration with
open source uh leading uh organizations
that enable us to tackle these uh
challenges um at the very lowest of
levels uh through our partnership with
uh unexpected time through our
partnership with intel
and with nvidia open source
so now how does it all work
um so that's what it looks like in a
nutshell infinity is a plug-and-play
solution that will deliver transformers
accuracy at millisecond latency
what it looks like is a container a
docker container an infinity container
that wraps all the optimized
logic to deliver an end-to-end inference
pipeline including the pre-processing
the post-processing and all the model
optimization around your model it
provides you with easy easy-to-use http
endpoints to run predictions and monitor
performance
and it also comes with what we call the
multiverse container which is a
self-serve service for you to optimize
your own model to make it compatible
with the infinity solution so you can
update retrain uh your models and still
work within your environment without
having to share your model with us
without having to send data out of your
environment and
infinity runs in every environment where
you can run a docker container whether
it's your aws or it's your azure your
gcp even in saves maker or in your
on-premise data center anywhere a docker
container can run
so to sum it up infinity is an optimized
solution delivering an end-to-end
inference pipelines leveraging all the
state-of-the-art techniques
that we've
pioneered through our science and open
source contributions it is fully
deployable in any environment with us in
a single container that you can scale um
as uh containerized solutions
and what's really unique about infinity
well first is a performance right that's
the reason why we went out to build it
but then it's also a solution that is
completely flexible where you can bring
your own model um you can fine-tune your
own model to work within infinity it
runs within your own environment so it's
out of the box enterprise ready
and secure
and you're in control of it you control
your model you control your data you
control your production environments
so what can you use it for
we really wanted to focus
on the largest volume use cases that we
saw through usage of our open source
and today that means focusing on the
model architectures and really working
deep
on those specific model architectures to
be able to provide
that acceleration
so semantic search is a huge a a huge
use case
where we can see uh bert like models
being used to extract embeddings and do
ranking
and then all tasks that you can perform
through vert-like models from text
classification to entity recognition
sentiment analysis
and other tasks
so let's let's look at the results we're
able to achieve now
one millisecond that is how low we're
able to pull down the latency
on a bird-like model on gpu this is
really breakthrough performance that
will enable a whole new breadth of use
cases
for the industry not just for big tech
but for every single company out there
and that's not all on cpu we were able
to achieve three milliseconds
for bert inference latency which is
amazing that means that you can run huge
workloads and have a great cost of
operation
for for your infrastructure so i'm
really excited for philip to demonstrate
that to you in a few minutes
but before
let's talk about the amazing partners
with whom we've worked over the past few
months
to really hone in on the infinity
solution
so auto one of the largest one of the
largest e-commerce companies in the
world
looking uh two hugging face
to build a new semantic search based
experience we're able to achieve two
milliseconds uh for the uh latency
of uh their model
and uh we have a little tape for you
philip if you want to roll it
so in there
hi we are phillip and jens from otto
since november 2020 we have been working
as part of team archie to explore new
opportunities of information retrieval
systems
we were able to reach around 2.3
milliseconds for the feature extraction
task and around 2.4 milliseconds for the
ranking task per data point
this is about 100 times faster than a
non-optimized model on cpu and 10 times
faster than on gpu
awesome
and uh thank you so much uh jensen
phillip for working with us on this
there is a lot more uh of otto's story
for you to discover if you go to our
landing page at
huggingface.com infinity
you learn more
about
how otto has been leveraging hugging
phase and infinity
to achieve those results next i want to
give a big shout out
to pete at penny hey pete i think you're
over here um with
infinity moneypenny the largest uh
outsourced conversation
service in the world we're able to
automate call transcript classification
using your bird-like models at the tune
of four milliseconds per call
so philip if you can roll the tape
let's hear what pete had to say
hi well my name is pete hanlon and i'm
the cto at moneypenny and we are the
number one outsourced communications
provider in the world
so we were able to process a year's
worth of conversations
in just over an hour
which is a massive improvement on
performance
awesome thanks pete and again
a lot more from pete and manny penny if
you go to our website at huggingface.com
infinity
so thanks to our
pilot partners we're able to really hone
in on
what can you do
when you're able to
increase
the performance to decrease the latency
10x like this a great engineering feed
but if i'm a product manager
what does this do for me
so the first thing is
if you're managing infrastructure
and you have a large scale workloads and
maybe you you use
20 gpus
on a constant basis
to run that workload well today with
infinity chances are you only need two
of those gpus and you can regain all
that infrastructure all that compute
back to power new features
the second thing you can do with a 10x
drop in latency is to increase the scale
at which you're able to leverage
transformers maybe today you use it to
classify customer tickets um well with
infinity or able to reach the scale that
enables you to
power many more features uh upon
transformers because you have now 10
times
more throughput
and then the last thing is speed a 10x
drop in latency means that experiences
that were not possible before are
becoming possible and in there any
custom facing use case where latency is
really important uh becomes possible
through transformers
all right
now now you know why we built infinity
you know how we built it
and here's the question how can you get
your hands on it
so what's available today we're
launching infinity in general
availability with a wide set of model
tasks and supported hardware
in terms of models there are seven
architectures that are available out of
the box
for birch distal birth roberta and mini
lm
downstream tasks
in terms of tasks you can use infinity
today to do embedding extraction and
re-ranking which are instrumental to
power semantic search and you can also
use infinity for sequence classification
tasks we are working on token
classification it will be available soon
let us know if this if there is a task
in there that you need
and then the last thing is hardware so i
mentioned our partnership with intel and
how we're able to really drill down to
the silicon to be able to extract as
much performance and efficiency as
possible um we have a great solution
that is optimized specifically for the
latest generation of xeon cpus cascade
lake cpus
so we recommend uh uh your cpn cpu
cpu-bound workloads um to power on those
but
infinities also uh also supports uh
skylake and earlier generations of xeon
cpus we're working with intel to enable
a great solution with new performance
gains on ice leg generation and then of
course on gpu uh the infinity solution
is optimized uh to take advantage of
tensor core technology of nvidia gpus
and how do you get your hands on it well
you should request a trial today
so the url to do so is hugging face dot
go slash infinity dash trial
we will just need uh some uh information
technical information to understand what
is the tasks that you're targeting what
is the model architecture that you want
to put in production uh what hardware do
you have available which production
environment
do you plan on deploying infinity in
and then the the main thing here is that
um you should do so as soon as possible
because our sales team is going to go
back to you to schedule technical
conversations on a first-come
first-served basis
so yeah request a trial today it's
huggingface.go slash infinity dash
trial
and with that i'm going to hand it off
to philip who's going to walk you
through a demo live on how you can
deploy infinity in your own environment
all right
thank you
so
before we start i would like to show you
how an infinity
repository is going to look like so it's
pretty similar to what we already have
with all the transformer models uh
infinity repository consists out of a
config json which contains all the
configuration we need to run the
infinity infinity container on your
dedicated hardware and infinity
model.bin which is basically a pandora
to the python model that bin and the
tokenizer
in this case it's like a mini lm model
fine tune for ssd2 and already optimized
for infinity which we are going to use
to run on a gpu
therefore
just need to switch the screen
and
go okay
so i'm on ec2 machine with an nvidia
or not with an nvidia
okay then let's start with the cpu okay
i will we will look into the gpu later
when my console is working again so with
the cpu um we are also achieving as jeff
said like three milliseconds per task
and in this case i already optimized the
sweller model in the temp directory
which containing our infinity model.bin
our tokenizer json and our config json
and to run infinity it's basically you
can use docker run to run it and that's
all you need so if you want to run it on
a kubernetes cluster it's basically you
need just the kubernetes configuration
for it but on a normal virtual machine
you can use docker run to run it and
infinity provides options to use storage
like remote storage in our case we are
using a mounted file system into our
container but um infinity support
storage options for de-hugging phase hub
amazon s3 and google cloud storage and
after a few
seconds our infinity container will be
started and for cpu you can see there we
are also out trending like the omp num
threads to see okay if the container is
like initialized properly and as you can
see we are not running on the biggest
cpu out there and in addition to this
we have
created
maybe i can open another tab
um
and by the way keep the great questions
coming we're responding to as many as we
can during the demo
i said
okay that's bad i'm on the wrong machine
um
but i can guess i can start it in a
detached mode and then we can see the
request time
one second
okay now the infinity container is
running and what we have done is we
created a python script to show you to
show you
how you can run your requests on it it's
a simple python script with an input of
16 token length and just iterating over
it until we are done basically
or not that's bad
okay let's let's go back to the gtu and
that should work
sorry for it
so we have a gpu here tensor core
where we can run our infinity container
with the model from the hugging phase
hub
and we can connect to it
on an additional machine with
ssh
and should see
our
python script
here as well perfect okay just one
second for the infinity container to be
started and then i can show you the one
millisecond for infinity on gpu
it's running now we can execute our
script with python3 requested pi
and here we can see our requests coming
in on the left side just logging on the
right side we can see we have
at the top and example output with our
probabilities for our task we are
running on ssd2 so it's sentiment
classification and we can see the one
millisecond 1.5 milliseconds for our
input token and some of you might say
yeah of course it's just 16 millisecond
16 tokens that's why you're that fast
therefore we prepared another script
with
a sequence length of 128
here you can see the input of it so it's
just like a text about heightened phase
and we are achieving for 128 sequence
lengths 2.5 to 2.6 milliseconds for gpu
and
while i'm setting up the uh last one i
get back to jeff's to answer a few
questions
thanks so much philip
wow 2.2.5 on gpu that's that's really
amazing um
okay so let me take some some of the
questions that i saw uh so first i have
a technical question i'm going to hand
it over to morgan
from cdart any limits on max token
length
yeah the token's length is mostly uh
ruled by the model itself so
if you have any bird model for instance
they are mostly trained for 512 tokens
and we will be looking at enabling some
more longer range models in the future
but at the moment uh bert is like always
512.
nice thanks and then i have a question
from vamshi also for morgan vampire
do you also support models with decoder
blocks what sort of performance gains
should we expect for gpt and bar
yeah so that's what we have on the
roadmap at the moment so currently as i
said we are mostly looking at dirt like
architecture so auto denoiser
we will of course look at a sequence to
sequence model and it requires a little
bit more of engineering works there and
uh you can expect the same kind of um i
mean if you take one inference call you
can take um something around
the same order of magnitude that we have
for bird
all right one more for you morgan a
question from brian what cpu
or gpu was used to achieve one
millisecond and three millisecond
latency with burp
so for the gpu part we were using nvidia
t4 uh gpu which are
are mostly available uh on any cloud
provider for inference uh and for the
cpu part i think we're using like m5
instances on aws or c5 something like
this which provide all the required
knobs uh on the other side to enable
very fast inference
nice
and uh i'm gonna take the the the easy
one does it support semantic search
right now yes absolutely
you can build your semantic search upon
the feature extraction task that is
implemented out of the box in infinity
and the re-ranking task
so yeah it's fully supported today
so i'm back with cpu sorry for like the
coincidence but somehow like my terminal
got disconnected i already started the
infinity cpu container and getting back
to like the question about which cpu we
use so we are running on a m5 and large
instance using two vcpus and a cascade
lake cpu under the hood and you can see
like the infinity api has started
properly for my fine tune ssd2 and again
i can use the
python
request script for it
to
achieve 2.4 to 2.5 millisecond for
and the input of this live event is
create i will sign up for infinity and
to show you that like the
cpu performance is also not getting very
bad when scaling up we have another um
yeah example script again with our
longer sequence there you can see we are
achieving under 10 milliseconds on cpu
with two cpu cores for a sequence length
of 128
okay
i guess chef you can take over again yes
i think i need to address the pricing
question because i see uh many people
who are asking about it
so we want to make it super simple
and we think the best way to do that
is to
price upon the number of containers
that will be needed to run the workload
uh that um that you're planning for
infinity so through the trial uh and
sign up for that trial at
infinity trial through that trial we'll
be able to work with you to
provide you with a cus
a container that works specifically uh
for your task um and through that trial
you'll be able to estimate how many
containers you will need considering
that one container means one model
running on one machine so it's basically
capacity
and
so yeah we'll set that up and our sales
team
will build that into a yearly contract
so you can use infinity in your own
environment in your own
on your own tasks
we don't have public pricing i'm not
going to get into that but just to set
orders of magnitude um the minimum
amount for a contract will be uh around
uh 20 000 a year
for one container one cpu
any uh
any other question
i have a question about how does
infinity semantic search compare to
china
so actually these solutions can work um
in full symbiotic symbiosis right you
can use infinity to
build the vector representation
of your text
and index that within a search engine
the china being elastic
whatever you're planning to use
through infinity you're able to build
this solution upon transformer based
models at
at uh
unprecedented
unprecedented speed sorry
um i had some questions around tasks uh
do we plan to support image
image transformers do we plan to support
machine translation
so yes as you know transformers today
conquered nlp but is fast expanding to
other modalities showing
state-of-the-art performance in speech
and computer vision tasks like image
classification object detection
so yes absolutely we plan to support
every downstream task that transformers
that are implemented within the
transformer open source library can
support we won't get there uh instantly
it will take us some time
but we plan to add every single task
that is supported by the library within
the infinity solution
i've i see a question about fine tuning
so is model fine tuning being done in a
similar way we do with the transformers
library
um i think the short answer is yes but
philip do you want to expand
yeah so basically you can like still
fine-tune your model as you would do
normally to run your infrared so you can
use transformers and the open source
libraries to fine-tune your model and
afterwards you can use the infiniti
moodle multiverse container to optimize
and convert the model for the infinity
container and then plug and play so you
don't need to change your fine-tuning
pipelines and fine-tuning scripts to use
infinity
at the end
all right
[Music]
is there any other question that you
guys want to take on um
i see some great great questions over
there uh thanks everybody for joining i
hope that you are as excited as we are
about the potential for infinity uh to
democratize the use
of transformer models in production at
companies
so we're excited to take on that
adventure with you um if you want us uh
to get back to you and set up a trial
please sign up as soon as possible uh
we're going to be taking in those
requests on a first come first serve
basis so the earlier you do
the earlier we'll be able to accommodate
you and set up that technical discussion
uh yeah thanks federico for
sharing that link
so it's just one click away
and
i will take one more question is there
going to be a video of this presentation
uh yes there will be a video of this
presentation
to request it you can
hit us up at infinity huggingface.com
all right
and so with this
i think um
i think we can wrap it up
and thanks everybody for joining
thanks
thanks everyone everyone
bye